it's almost Australia day we seriously
I'd fit right in with your proud nation
with its shady criminal past in its
predilection for black out drinking and
unrelenting condescension toward New
Zealand only one teeny problem you gave
us Wolverine and for that I can't
forgive you I've got no problems with
you I mean he's a delightful guy really
is true legend but the movie that was a
career-low for me you understand anywho
why am I here oh right uh happy
Australia Day cuz that's a real thing
you throw another shrimp on the barbie I
know you say that one's it too oh [ __ ]
that's a hat you guys wear this cuz I
was getting swarmed by [ __ ] diddly
Australian bees
hey youtubers is Charlie happy Australia
Day even though most of you do not live
in Australia
the funny thing about this teaser is
that Fox is just not worried at all
about making fun of itself which is why
I love it
top 5 reasons why Deadpool's marketing
campaign is the best marketing campaign
of any movie ever all 5 would be because
they're not afraid to make fun of
themselves or make fun of other films
the biggest reason I think they're able
to pull it off is just because it's on
brand with Deadpool Deadpool's character
does that all the time in the comics
he's not afraid to make fun of anybody
even when they're trying to kill him but
here's something that we need to debate
in the comics the absolute worst Marvel
film from Fox now is Ryan Reynolds says
Wolverine Hugh Jackman awesome Wolverine
the movie career low point for him just
very very tongue-in-cheek
but is Wolverine Origins a worse film
than fantastic for the newer Fantastic
Four or x-men 3 last stand I will argue
that Wolverine Origins is not the worst
Fox film because it's a little more
tongue-in-cheek with the humor and it's
just a lot of money shots strung
together with some weak dialogue it's
it's not like a complete disaster like
the Fantastic Four movie was and it's
not something that tries to take itself
super seriously without being successful
like x-men 3 so really the battle for
the bottom is between Fantastic Four and
X 3 and it sounds like you know based on
a lot of the concept art for Fantastic
Four it at least started out as an
interesting movie and then just through
the process just turned into a complete
nightmare
x3 despite having some very interesting
things in it like they had some really
interesting characters some interesting
situations which just from start to
finish just completely terrible had tip
to Brett Ratner for following one of the
best x-men films ever x2 with one of the
worst x-men films ever you just I feel
like he's capable of doing a big action
comedy film rush hour is an entertaining
film I just feel like he didn't fit into
the Bryan Singer x-men universe very
well and part of the problem is is that
if you're not used to storytelling with
characters like that it can completely
go off the deep end it is really hard
for a new director and a new writer to
come in if they're not used to making
characters like that believable in both
cases though Fantastic Four x3
completely wiped off the continuity map
Fantastic Four will probably be rebooted
with a whole new team whole new actors
writer-director in like three or four
years fox is allowed like based on the
contract that Fox has for Fantastic Four
they're allowed to continue making
Fantastic Four films as long as they
continue making Fantastic Four films so
the minute that they stop like if they
ever stopped then the rights would go
back to Marvel so even if Fantastic Four
never makes a truckload of money they're
still going to keep making fantastic
four films and yeah probably eventually
you'll see some sort of crossover where
you see like Reed Richards go into the
x-men franchise I think that's part of
the idea if they're going to be doing
cable and Deadpool x-force a New Mutants
movie then of course they're going to
want to bring this universe together
everybody wants to do the Marvel thing
now every studio with every franchise
they can find getting back to terrible
movies though I feel like you know one
of the reasons why a lot of these films
don't turn out great is because the
story isn't there like they try to water
down they try to like sand off all the
really interesting things so it's
acceptable to everyone all over the
world where you bring in a team with
some interesting ideas but they don't
really have the power to see that vision
through the studio process like if you
bring in a brand new director who's not
really powerful like Fantastic Four a
lot of great ideas in the concept stage
but the director was clearly not
powerful enough to overrule the studio
on certain decisions most big comic book
films even the Marvel films are made by
committee one of the rare examples
though is when you get a guy like
Christopher Nolan who is super powerful
who can make decisions and if someone at
the studio is like no you know I don't I
don't want it to look like that we don't
like the way this character is talking
we don't like the scene he can say nope
we're going to do it my way
very few directors are that powerful
even Marvel held Avengers age of Ultron
hostage from Joss Whedon based on a
couple cuts that they were conflicting
over there were a bunch of dream
sequences that got cut out Joss Whedon
wanted in the movie but Marvel didn't
want them they said if you don't let us
include this other scene that we wanted
we're going to cut out all these dream
sequences every single one of them
because Joss Whedon wanted the movie to
be a little more cerebral so even a guy
like Joss Whedon has to bow to the
studio when the dollar value the movie
goes above a certain point I think
behind the scenes with Deadpool one of
the reasons why this film looks a lot
more fun it's just because Fox
been through the process with fantastic
for you know complete disaster
so they double down on creative tried to
work with the comic-book people brought
in people like Rob Liefeld and it became
something more that fans would enjoy so
I think that's why Deadpool is going to
hit with audiences a little bit more
Ryan Reynolds has already talked about
Deadpool and cable along with the writer
of this movie they're like if we didn't
put cable in the sequel people would
assassinate us so it sounds like they
are really hype about getting cable into
the Deadpool movies but even if cable
winds up in the Deadpool sequel I think
he's also going to be in the x-force
film too but they haven't confirmed
anything yet let me know in the comments
though worst Fox Marvel film of all time
and when do you want to see cable first
do you want to see him in x-force first
or do you want to see him in the
Deadpool sequel what's going to happen
next is is I'm going to circle back
around and get some DC movie stuff I'll
do another Suicide Squad video Batman V
Superman Justice League there's just
like so much stuff to talk about because
they drop so much footage this week so
be sure to subscribe to get everything
I'll do some more Deadpool next week if
there's anything you guys want me to do
for bonus video any cable videos or
anything like that just let me know in
the comments
so why you guys wait for everything to
post you can click here for all my
Deadpool videos and you can click here
for the Game of Thrones teaser I just
posted they just posted a big teaser
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you